بعد ما هنا ابنته الف مبروك للعروسه ولام
العروس انت طالق بالثلاثه تداول رواد
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو
لمصريا يطلق زوجته امام الحاضرين اثناء
حفل زفاف ابنته ما تسمم بصدمه للحضور
[موسيقى]
الا بالنسبه لام العروسه
جماهير السعوديه لتشجيع المنتخب الاخضر
امام بولندا ضمن بطوله كاس العالم الحاليه
بقلد فهد عتيبي هذه بلاد ياسر الشهراني
[موسيقى]
قضيه الفنانه منه شلبي الجدل بشان عدم
خدوعها لتحليل المخدرات وعدم حبسها
احتياطيا مثل ما يحدث في معظم القضايا
المتعلقه بضبط مواد يشبه في كونها مخدرات
حيث اوضح مصدر قضائي مصري ان نيابه تعاملت
مع الفنانه منه شلبي كغيرها من القضايا
التي يتم عرضها عليها ولم تحصل الفنانه
على مميزات خاصه وهو اخلاء السبيل بالضمان
المالي في كل نيابات على مستوى الجمهوريه
ذاكرا انه لا يحبس في الطاعات الا من يضبط
بكميات تكون عاده
في مشهد طريفا وغير مالوف الشرطه الكنديه
تطارد نعامه هاربه من احدى حظائر مدينه
كابر التابعه لمقاطعه البرتا وذلك بعد
هروب نحوي 20 عاما من حظيره
ما تسبب في تعطل حركه المرور في شوارع
المدينه
فضيحه مدويه احدى اكبر ماركات الموضه
الفاخره في العالم تعتذروا بعد انتشار
مجموعه صور لحمله دعائيه اعتبرها كثيرون
مسيئه للاطفال وترويجوا للاعتداءات
الجنسيه بحقهم الماركه هي بلنسيه بلنسياغا
وقد وعدت باتخاذ اجراءات قاسيه بعد انتشار
صور للعارضين للاطفال الذين ظهروا مع
اكسسوارات جنسيا واشارات تدل على قضايا
قانونيه تتعلق بالاعتداء على الاطفال عالم
الموضه يبدو تماما تحت الصدمه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء